[Music]
foreign
hi
my name is Addie Shankar I'm a TV and
movie producer you may know me from the
Castlevania animated series on Netflix
or one of my fan fiction shorts on
YouTube
seven years ago I got a call from
Ubisoft offering me the opportunity to
adapt one of their uh very very very
serious franchises into an anime
but instead I came back to them with a
crazy concept inspired by the the mood
of Far Cry 3 blood Dragon
yeah
this concept used ubisoft's vast library
of characters and remixed them into one
Delirious anime series
that would become This Love Letter to
the 90s
or at least how I remember the 90s
and to my absolute surprise Ubisoft said
no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just kidding they said yes
that's why I'm up here
come on
this is a story of how the first anime
series by Ubisoft was born
Captain laser Hawk
a blood dragon remix
this show is many things
it's violent
it's a dystopian fiction in the spirit
of the works of Aldous Huxley it's a
spoof it's a satire
it's dark comedy
it's a love story
and as a descendant of Indian Mystics
I can tell you it's the most
philosophically conscious
show
you've watched in a long time
the series was picked up by Netflix
it was animated by the Renegade genius
Pirates at Bobby pills Studio
and today
I'm very happy to announce that barring
an apocalypse
which may happen
it will be released worldwide later this
year
and that's not all
I'm even more excited to share with you
an action-packed Easter egg filled
teaser trailer right now
[Applause]
don't change the channel
[Music]
foreign